[Music]
welcome to another episode of what's up
prof
good day walter good morning martin how
are you
i am very well thank you oh that's good
i'm glad it's well with you if it's not
well
then we have to turn to the bible
because lord says
we can bring everything to him yes
maybe that's the only reason why things
on occasion go well
let's open with a word of prayer that we
can start our discussion
our heavenly father we ask you to please
help us through this discussion it's an
important discussion
and it's a sensitive subject so we ask
you to please help us
and enlighten our minds and the viewers
in jesus name
amen amen
yeah we're going to talk about true and
false prophets right yes
and we're going to have a look at what
some people are saying in the world
and uh let's just put a qualifier
in there and ask a question before we
start
deception in the world is
it a very rare thing or is it
commonplace
no it's commonplace and the people
that are deceived do they know that they
are deceived
no because what's the point of deception
then
so martin do you think that uh somebody
who
is deceiving now in a spiritual sense
do you think that they are deliberate or
are they themselves deceived
no i think they themselves are also
deceived
okay if there were no deception
would we not all believe exactly the
same thing
yes i believe you would how many
denominations are there out there in the
world
thousands thousands and
amongst them which one believes that he
is
right everyone okay now in your own life
you were always on the religious
wavelength me i was on the atheistic
wavelength so while you were on
the religious wavelength did you always
stay
with one denomination or did you go
hopping
no i went topping why did you go hopping
because every time i've
learned something new and then i thought
that was the truth
so you thought the other one was not
quite on the right wavelength
and you went and found something else
and then you said well now you're on the
right wavelength and eventually you
jumped
right across the wavelengths right yeah
so that's the name of the game
now who is the master of deception satan
satan himself and he's a master
do you think he could even deceive
unfallen perfect beings
yes he did he did right
so how much more so yeah fallen beings
now do people in this world
have a natural affinity for truth and
righteousness
unfortunately not are you sure about
that yes
how sure i'm very sure okay
so there's a natural affinity for
unrighteousness
yes it's called the fallen nature right
and who can help us with that
only god only god can all right
but now the bible itself warns and says
be careful that nobody deceives you so
deception is going to be the name of the
game right
yes now what is the criterium as to
whether you are deceived or not must be
the word oh
of course all right here is written
what we need this is the road map
so when moses wrote the first five books
of the bible
and probably the book of job
and a number of the psalms that was the
road map for them
and god said be careful that you do not
move to the left or to the right
yes and the israelites said
all that you say we will do
and they kept their promise right did
they
no no and did this eventually get lost
yes and then
somewhere on a dusty shelf somewhere
they would find the book of the law and
there would be great excitement
and they'd come out and say we found the
book of the law and they would read
to some of the kings and they would tear
their clothes
and say ah how far we have wandered from
this isn't that correct yes
and then there'd be reform and others
would say
throw that scroll in the fire i don't
hear it right
so this has been a war ever since time
immemorial
so we can expect the same thing today
so we don't want to be hard
on anybody now
one of the things that is very prevalent
today
is the notion that people are led by the
spirit because there is a manifestation
correct all right so the idea then
is if the manifestation is there
then that must be the spirit but what if
you find that
same manifestation
in cultures that know nothing about the
bible
yeah what if across the board of
religious systems in the world
even down to shamanism or
wiccanism you find similar
manifestations
is the manifestation then a guarantee
that this is truth no no
not at all so when the reformation took
place
they realized one very important
principle sola
scriptura the bible
and the bible alone can
be your guarantee
the standard the standard now does that
exclude spiritual manifestations
no no and this is where it becomes
tricky that's why you must test the
spirit that's why you must test the
spirits because
there obviously will
be a relationship with god
if you have accepted
jesus as your personal savior for
example
then this communication
becomes natural
is it possible that the devil
could uh involve himself
and try and steer you off the right path
definitely
okay so the bible tells us
you must watch yeah you must watch you
must be
constantly vigilant you must put on the
whole armor of god
and that is your only safeguard
and if you get a message to assume that
this message
is from god without verifying it in the
word of god
is a very dangerous thing to do
but it happens and so
even the elect yes
can be deceived that is a very serious
issue
so let's not be too hard but let's look
at some of the criteria
and let's make sure we understand the
criteria
and then we can see whether something
is in harmony with god's principles or
not yes
that's how we should approach it so
obviously
we're going to do that we cannot deal
with the
prophecies immediately we must first see
what the criteria is
that we can study what is true and what
is false
correct so let's bear with each other
and
let's have a look what the bible has to
say
so whenever god has revealed himself to
man it was either in a dream
vision or god veiled his glory
right if god appeared to someone
he veiled it when he appeared to moses
he was in a burning bush
right or he failed his divinity in the
form
of humanity so when god spoke to israel
from mount sinai
he warned them that they would die if
they were to come to close
so that was an excellent display of
god's glory
so much so that you had to keep your
distance
the presence of god although veiled in
thick clouds
was so impressive that the people
requested moses to speak to them the
words of god
lest they should die from the voice of
god they were scared right
even a goat or an animal that came too
close that was a problem
and it wasn't god destroying it no it's
just how
glorious god is
and he said make sure that your animals
are safe keep them away
don't you come closer and it'll take a
very special protection
but even moses in the cloud
was speaking face to face but there was
still a cloud yeah
and when he came down he was shining
that the people who could almost not
look at him exactly so it put a veil on
his face
the prophets of old even in vision felt
that they would die in the presence of
god
yeah so here's an example isaiah chapter
5 then said i woe is me
for i am undone because i am a man of
unclean lips and i dwell in the midst of
a people of
unclean lips for mine eyes have seen the
king the lord of hosts
he's undone he's done with and if you
you read through the bible you'll see
that the judges too
when they had a communication with god
said we're going to die we've
seen god right and in new testament
times it
was no different when john saw jesus
envision he fell as one dead revelation
1 17 and when i saw him
i fell at his feet as dead
and he laid his right hand upon me
saying unto me fear not
i am the first and the last. so this
is a common experience
now do you think satan could can't
defeat that
could someone when he is in the presence
of god
fall down yes
yes yes isn't that so if you look at
some of the church meetings
they say fire and everybody
falls down so
when is it a manifestation from god and
when
is it a manifestation from a counterfeit
experience
we'll have to see so throughout the ages
god communicated his will
to his servants the prophets and when
the people heard it they said this
is wonderful we will do this right
unfortunately not
no so anything
that is immediately uh extremely popular
must be extremely suspect
yes that's the first thing you must do
that's the first thing
yeah caution if it sounds too good to be
true it
probably is right
amos 3 verse 7 says surely the lord god
will do
nothing but he reveals his secrets
unto his servants the prophets you know
that's a very
gratifying promise
so you're not going to grope in the dark
god is not going to say like the
deist opinion of god god created man he
doesn't care about him
man continues down here whether he
messes up or not god is not interested
no god is very concerned
about his creation and he
will make sure that the path
is known so he will reveal his secrets
to his servants the prophets and people
can go
and see and decide
and test whether they want to walk that
way
or not that decision still lies with man
so this
this revealing to the prophets is
done in the bible and then any revealing
that's been done
in the modern day has to be tested has
to be tested by the bible so we need the
criteria
these prophets did not speak their own
words but revealed
god's will to man ii peter
1 21 says for prophecy came not in old
time by the will of man but holy men of
god
spake because they were moved by the
holy ghost
and and by the way when some of these
prophets heard
what god had to say were they all
enthusiastic to give the message
no no because they knew boy this is
trouble
yeah okay here's another great idea it's
a it's not a popular message
i'm not gonna be popular and you could
just
be stoned yes
so prophets chosen by god have been used
by god
since the fall acts 3 verse 21 says
god has spoken by the mouth of his holy
prophet
since the world began
so god is not lax in communicating his
will to man
he wants you to know
but human nature is naturally in
rebellion
and doesn't want to know and
that has not changed no no no
now the bible tells us you mustn't
despise prophecy
despise not prophesying 1 thessalonians
20. now if there are so many false
prophets out there
and you're not supposed to despise
prophesying
that means that you must go on a course
of discernment correct right yes
because do you want to be deceived no
nobody wants to be deceived
but the devil is such a master at it
right
second chronicles 20 20 believe in the
lord your god
so shall ye be established believe his
prophets
so shall ye prosper
now the key word here is his
correct believe his prophets
that means i must be sure that i'm
listening
to his prophet and not a false prophet
and since prophecy is so unpopular
most people will try to say that the
true prophet
is a false prophet that's it and you
know what martin
that becomes the interesting criteria
when a prophet is
most attacked
then it's time to go and look at that
prophet
what is that prophet saying right
because all the prophets of the bible
were ridiculed already and they were
and poor although i was sewn in half
right
they didn't have a very popular um
following now when you look at the
parables of jesus
didn't he say how it went with these
prophets
yes and i sent you the prophets and what
did you do with them
some of them you threw in prisons and
some of them you scourged
some of them you stoned to death
some of them were tortured it was
horrendous
right whilst on the other hand there is
the warning against false prophets
matthew 24 24 therefore there shall
arise
false christs false prophets and shall
sow great
signs and wonders in so much that if it
were possible
they shall deceive the very elect
obviously it is possible yes otherwise
you wouldn't warn against it
so let's have a look at how to test
whether a prophet is from god
or whether he or she is
not from god
there are seven criteria which we will
briefly go through number one
a true prophet's message will be in
complete
harmony with the word of god and the law
of god
isaiah 8 20 to the law
and to the testimony now the law there
is the torah
and that is generally the portion
written by moses
so whatever comes thereafter has to be
in harmony with what moses wrote yes
now martin people that say
that you can ignore the old testament
and only rely on the new testament
aren't they in trouble here
yes because it's got to be in harmony
with the torah
and that's the books that moses wrote
you're throwing out the first part that
is the basis
of testing if you're speaking according
to the word
correct okay so this is the problem so
does this portion the book of the law
does it contain the ten commandments yes
correct right
does it contain civil laws yes does it
contain health laws
yes all of them are there right
everything is in the first five
now some of the laws no longer apply
because god said if you choose a king
then obviously the civil laws will
revert to the king's authority
and he said you will regret it yeah if
you choose a king
because he's going to take your best man
and he's going to
fight his wars that he wants to fight
and some of those wars might not be wars
there
where i am involved and you are going to
see
people die like flies and he'll take
your choice ladies
and he'll bring them into his courts and
you
will basically be subjected to an
authority that is not always in harmony
with god yes he warned them
right before they went on to we're
sitting with that mess to this day
right yeah and one pharaoh says he's
going to be better than the previous
pharaoh
and often we are still waiting for that
good pharaoh to come ryan
all right so it's got to be in harmony
with the books of moses
it's got to be in harmony with the ten
commandments it's got to be in harmony
with everything that is written there
and if they speak not according to this
word it is because there is no light in
them
so most modern day prophets would fail
this test
would you agree with that martin yes a
prophet cannot negate what god has
revealed in his word
and all the precepts of the law are
binding
correct yep now there are some laws
in the torah which
are no longer binding so
how can we say all are binding
well you have the ceremonial law and
then you have the moral law
right you have the health laws and
laws of conduct which are spelt out
which are in harmony with the ten
commandments for example
but the ceremonial law isn't actually
gone
it's just been fulfilled in christ
correct correct so
everything still stands so if you want
to understand the ministry of christ for
example
then you must understand the ceremonial
law yes
and the same with the the laws
when god was in the um with them in a
theocracy
yes then there were certain laws that
immediately if somebody did something
he must be put to death yes that doesn't
change
because at the end when god jesus comes
the second time
and for eternity those people that
transgressed
will eventually also not exist again
so what you're saying is the penalty has
not been removed it's just been
postponed
exactly so if you want to understand the
ministry of christ
and you want to see is christ now
the real christ or is he
a false christ didn't he warn that there
would be false christs yes
yes so how do i determine whether this
is the real one or whether this is the
false one
to the law and to the testimony so if
christ
fulfills all the criteria
how many of them all the criteria of the
ceremonial
law then he must be the true christ yes
if he does not then he must be a
false christ so must you understand the
ceremonial law
definitely yes not because we need to be
circumcised or follow all the rituals
that
pointed to him but you must understand
it yes
okay all of that had a spiritual
application correct
so this is the very very important
criterium
and the law and the testimony this word
testimony
it's very irritating to some people in
the modern world
the testimony of jesus so the testimony
of jesus
is what god has revealed to prophets
other than moses yes that's the
testimony
so if i take this bible and i read the
book of isaiah
what am i reading a testimony if i read
jeremiah what am i reading testimony of
jesus
testimony of jesus because who gave that
prophecy to jeremiah jesus
who gave it to moses moses jesus jesus
and to all the prophets and to all the
prophets now if a prophet arises today
a modern-day prophet and jesus gives him
a message
then it must be in harmony with the
torah what moses wrote yes
and it must be in harmony with all the
other prophets because jesus christ the
same yesterday today and forever he
doesn't change
he's not going to change his view oh i
made a mistake
that didn't work guys let's try
something else let's get rid of the law
for example we discussed that
last time it was to our show those
people couldn't make it so i'll rather
be
a little bit i was so mean in the old
testament if people didn't listen
they were destroyed i'm going to change
my tactics
no then you totally misunderstand the
character of god
in the typologies where people were
removed
from society that was mercy yes
they had reached the point of no return
and their probation was closed
all that they would achieve thereafter
would be to the destruction of those
that remain
now if you look at the modern world and
you look
at how sin has become popularized and
rampant yes you stand astounded
do you think you can take that ship and
just
turn it around and everybody will become
righteous
so there comes a point where god says
they've passed the point of
no return they cannot turn around
anymore
and that will lead to the point of final
destruction there will be individuals
amongst them that listen to the small
still voice and turn
around and come out that's why jesus
says come out of her my people
and no matter how bad your situation is
you can come out
but you must want to come out
so modern-day prophets would fail the
test james tells us in james 2 10 for
whosoever shall keep the whole law
and yet offend in one point he is guilty
of all
that's quite something yeah so you must
keep the whole of the bible
because it's the law and the testimony
so when the law is not observed then the
gift of prophecy is withdrawn
because that's the criterium to the law
and to the testimony if they speak not
according to this word there's no light
in them
and if people have turned their back on
the law of god
then they cannot speak in harmony with
so anybody that prophesies
and says that the law is not binding
must by definition already be a false
prophet
correct so if somebody says
god changed his mind and he changed the
seventh day to the first day
can he be a true prophet no no it's not
in harmony with the law
exactly with the torah it's not in
harmony with the testimony
it's not difficult to realize if you're
not in harmony
sorry that's it that's it so immediately
you know
there's something here all right now
again it's very tricky it's not it's not
quite so clear-cut
because does that mean that god never
impresses
anybody that is deceived and is
doing the wrong things because he
doesn't even know that it's wrong
doesn't god want to save them too
exactly okay so to say
that only those who have now discovered
that the law is binding
only those are righteous and saved now
all of us are unrighteous
it is grace that saves us right yes by
faith
so the leading of the holy spirit it's
just like a parent
the wayward child you don't say to the
wayward child oh well you're wayward
away with you no that's the one that
gets your
most attention right
and god in his wisdom sometimes allows
the wayward child to learn his lesson
so let's say the child let's let's be
real gruesome now and say the child
loves to play with fire
and uh you warn the child and the child
keeps putting his finger near the fire
eventually
you discipline the child because you
don't want him to be hurt
and he refuses to budge
sometimes the parent with limitations
will allow them to experience the
consequences of their actions
right correct and maybe that'll teach
them a lesson
so the same way
god also works with people today
so the second point is a true prophet's
predictions must come to pass
and even that's a tricky one yes because
there's also sometimes conditions
correct so if you take
jonah for example jonah
didn't want to prophesy because he was
scared
that his message wouldn't be accepted in
the first place
in the second place the ninevites were
hated by israel and here he goes
to warn the ninevites that is something
that doesn't sit well with some people
and the worst of all for jonah is what
if they repent
yeah then then he's a false prophet
then he'll be a false prophet if god
relents from
what he has said so jeremiah 28 verse 9
says
the prophet which prophesies of peace
when the word of the prophet shall come
to pass
then shall the prophet be known that the
lord has truly sent
him because it's very seldom
that peace will actually be prophesied
normally god sends a warning right
deuteronomy 18 22 says when a prophet
speaks in the name of the lord
if the thing follow not nor come to pass
that is the thing which the lord has not
spoken
but the prophet has spoken it
presumptuously
thou shalt not be afraid of him
presumption is satan's counterfeit for
faith
yes so we have to be very careful of the
synonymous
presumption it's so close together those
two yes that's why jesus
had to face the sin of presumption in
the conflict with the devil right in the
wilderness
if you're the son of god then why so
hungry turn these
stones into bread you can do it that's
that's the sin of presumption a word of
warning
seems in order here a prophet's
predictions may come true and he or she
may even perform
miracles to convince you of the genuine
of the prophecy yet it may be false
that's jonah for example and a miracle
to substantiate something could be a
false miracle too
don't be so careful yeah when you go to
a spiritist these days
and a clairvoyant and they tell you
certain things that will happen
in your life do some of them actually
happen for example yes
they could right oh immediately that is
a very safe prophet right
aha but is that prophet living according
to the law and to the testimony
that's the criterium then stay away
because they're definitely not living
according to the law and the testimony
deuteronomy 13 1-4 says if they arise
amongst you a prophet or a dreamer of
dreams
and give us the a sign or a wonder and
the sign or the wonder come to pass
whereof he spoke unto thee saying let us
go after other gods
which thou has not known and let us
serve them
thou shalt not hearken unto the words of
that prophet
so something can actually come true what
the prophet says
he gives you a sign and it happens and
it happens yeah and he says god has told
us we must go
and worship at the throne of malach
[Music]
when the torah warns that there's only
one god
and you may not worship other gods yeah
that prophet has speaking presumptuously
no matter how many of his signs and
wonders
has come true actually come true or that
dreamer of dreams for the lord your god
proveth you to know whether you love the
lord your god with all your heart and
with all your soul
you shall walk after the lord your god
and fear him and keep his commandments
and obey his voice and you shall serve
him and cleave
unto him so now the bible also tells us
god tempts nobody
so basically he's saying that the lord
permits yeah
the enemy to tempt you did he permit the
enemy to tempt
adam and eve yes why would he do that
free will free will right
yes not to create
robots for the sake of fairness
for the sake of fairness in a court of
law
there will be a advocate for and there
will be an advocate against
why because fear fairness
and then the facts must determine who is
guilty and who is not guilty right
signs and wonders are not a test of
genuineness
as in the above scriptural example the
prophet's words were not in harmony with
the law of god
satan will work miracles in the last
days to deceive
many according to revelation 16 verse 14
all right so the third criterium a true
prophet prophesies to edify the church
counseling and advising in religious
matters
a prophet comes from god's people
it is seldom that the prophet
like in the case of jonah is sent to a
foreign nation then there's a very
specific command
yes go to nineveh and tell them
this that and the other but a prophet
normally is there to edify god's people
and therefore many of the things will
not be understood because not everybody
is in harmony with god's word right
and also most of the time the prophet
is there to bring the church back in
harmony
with god correct and
why does he raise up prophets for
very specific events that are going to
take place
and to bring god's people back from the
false road on which they have traveled
1 corinthians 14 3 and 4
but he that prophesies speakers unto men
to edification
exhortation and comfort he that
prophesies
edified the church god's
people and that church will also be
keeping the law and the testimony it
must keep the law in the testimony and
it will bring them that prophet will
bring them back the whole time
so if you go to the final church in
revelation 12
verse 17 what does it say there
the remnant that keeps the commandments
of god and as
the testimony of jesus exactly so the
criteria
are the same today that is the church
that you're speaking and that's the new
testament speaking
so the fourth criterium is a true
prophet shall exalt christ
as the son of god and the savior of
mankind
where did moses exalt christ well
in the ceremonial laws yes and then he
also said there will a prophet will
arise
after me that you will that you will
hear
him you will hear one like me right so
he was the type of christ
and he said that one will come and he
gave the entire sacrificial system
pointing to christ
so he will exalt christ 1 john 4
12 15 no man has seen god at
any time if we love one another god
dwelleth in us
and his love is perfected in us
whosoever shall confess that
jesus is the son of god god dwelleth
in him and he in god
so what did jesus say to peter when
all the disciples left
he said to the disciples
do you also want to go and he said
and peter said where can we go you've
got the truth
you have the words of eternal life
there's nowhere else to go
and he also said you
are the son of god the son of the living
god.
so when jesus after his resurrection
expounded the scriptures to his
disciples
he revealed to them the prophetic
proclamation regarding himself
and beginning at moses
and all the prophets he expounded unto
them
in all the scriptures the things
concerning himself
and what did they say those two did not
this word burn in our hearts
right i've never seen it well i never
understood this typology i never read
this before exactly
it comes back to what you said earlier
you cannot throw away
the old testament because jesus used the
old testament to
show that it pointed to him exactly
so it makes absolutely no sense to
discard
the old testament so a test for a true
prophet again a word of warning
regarding this test
many false prophets will say to jesus in
the last judgment
lord lord have we not prophesied in thy
name and in thy name have cast out
devils and in thy
name done many wonderful works
so again you can exalt jesus yes
and not be in harmony with the torah
exactly
so that's the scary part that's the
scary part so
today you have people that exalt jesus
and they negate the law and then you
have people today who exalt the law and
negate jesus
both are in trouble both both are in
trouble that's a very important
criterion
there's a fifth criterium a true prophet
will speak with
authority
even king said i don't want to hear him
there's one here that he's the prophet
of god
but i hate him yeah he never says
anything good
yes we can either listen to the other
400 or so listen to the other 400 yeah
bring the prophets of baal at least you
know their voices music to my ears
but the true prophet spoke with
authority you would say to a king you
who are living in transgression of god's
law
did john do that john john the baptist
yes what did he say to herod
you're living unlawfully with your wife
oh man it cost him his head right yeah
yeah well he even he spoke that
like that to the pharisees as well and
you brood of vipers
he had authority yeah
matthew 7 verse 29 and he taught them as
one having authority
and not as the scribes and the people
wondered
at the beauty that jesus brought out of
the bible right and it was all the old
testament as you said
so number six the true prophet will bear
good fruit
you can't be a prophet of god
and not live in harmony
with god's word that doesn't mean that
the prophet doesn't have
faults that doesn't mean that a prophet
can't fall that doesn't mean that the
prophet cannot despair
but there must be fruits in that
prophet's life which show you
that he believes the word and wants to
live in harmony with
it so matthew 7 20 says wherefore by
their fruits you
shall know them those are six criterium
now the seventh one gets interesting
the true prophet when envision will
exhibit
physical signs now this is very
important when in vision
now a prophet can dream dreams
uh a prophet can
have an opinion based on the bible
but when the prophet is in vision
that's something else then there will be
certain criteria
and here again we have to be very
careful
so in vision the prophet's eyes will be
open numbers 24
verse 4. now all the verses that we have
here are from the king james bible
and when we take the modern bibles we
have to be very very careful
now the modern bibles as we've discussed
many times
are dynamic equivalent
bibles and i always say
they might be very dynamic but they're
often
very far from equivalent
what does dynamic equivalent
mean it means it is
an interpretation of what god said
now who's the interpreter you man
man whoever is writing
those words right so let's say the
theologians
are the determiners of what
god said then it is not
directly what god said but it is an
interpretation and explanation according
to the mind
of the person doing it as to what god
said that's dynamic equivalent
good now when i tell you a story
and you tell the story in your own words
to someone else
and that person tells it to someone else
eventually 10 down the line 20 down the
line you compare the first story to the
last story
what do you get no two different stories
absolutely chaos right
now this is the danger
i would always like to know what
did god say and not
what did the translator think god says
so i like a direct translation
what did god say and the king james is a
direct translation
the old bibles that are based
on the received text they
are normally direct translation because
if you get a direct translation
from the other manuscripts it can be the
best direct translation but
the source is not yes so the the source
is important
and you have to ask yourself where did
the source come from
was it a clean spring
or was it a polluted system so all of
these things are very important so
let's read what a direct translation
says
he has said which heard the words of god
which saw the vision of the almighty
falling into a trance another into a
vision
but having his eyes open
that's direct so two pointers are here
of significance firstly the prophet
falls to the ground
is falling and secondly his or her eyes
are wide open the king james version
renders the translation from the
original text very precisely and for
this reason it is quoted above
the modern bible translations do not
bring these points
to light clearly the niv for example
translates the text as follows numbers
4 the oracle of one who hears the words
of god
who sees the vision from the almighty
who falls prostrate
and whose eyes are opened
now this could be in a spiritual context
yes right
so aha now i understand exactly but
that's not what it said that's an
interpretation
based on the word of god but the word of
god says his eyes are open
when he falls down so the issue of the
wide
open eyes is lost and can be interpreted
in a spiritual rather than
in a literal sense so let's take a look
at daniel for example the physical state
of the prophet while in vision
is carefully described in the bible why
would god do that
to make sure that you don't get
uh deceived if he's true or not okay
daniel 10 7 to 9 and i daniel
alone saw the vision for the men that
were with me
saw not the vision so he was chosen as
the prophet right
but a great quaking fell upon them
so that they fled to hide themselves
therefore i was left alone
and saw this great vision and there
remained
no strength in me
for my comeliness was turned unto me
unto corruption
and i retained no strength
yet heard i the voice of his words
and when i heard the voice of his words
then
was i in a deep sleep on my face
and my face to the ground
so what are the criteria he had no
strength
and he must have fallen to the ground as
he lay with his face on the ground right
yeah the prophet does not ever remain
in this helpless state on the ground but
he is lifted up by god and while still
in vision stands up on his feet
daniel 10 verses 10 and 11 and behold
the hand
touched me which set me upon my knees
and upon the palms of my hands and he
said unto me o daniel
o man greatly beloved understand the
words that i speak unto thee
and stand upright for unto thee
am i now sent and when he had spoken
this word unto me
i stood trembling so he's getting up
right
so in vision secondly a prophet will
have no breath in him
and no strength of his own
daniel 10 16 and 17 and behold one
like the similitude of the sons of men
touched my lips
and i opened my mouth and spake so he's
speaking
and i said unto him that stood before me
o my lord by the vision my
sorrows are turned upon me and i have
retained no strength
for how can the servant of this my lord
talk with this my lord for as for me
straightway there remaineth no strength
in me
neither is there breath left
in me there's no breath he's not
breathing
he's in a state of
life maintained by god without breath
so note that daniel has no strength
because of his vision he's touched by
god
speaks although there is no breath in
him
and again the new translations obscure
these vital texts by means of
interpretive rather than literal
translation let's see what the niv does
how can i your servant talk with you my
lord
my strength is gone and i can hardly
breathe
it doesn't say that that's an
interpretation
in me there's no breath not
i can hardly breathe so tests for a true
prophet
no mention is made of the restoration of
breeding
while in vision the prophecy is
sustained
by god whilst in vision and in summary
we can say he falls down
weak right secondly is raised up and
strengthened by god
now when god strengthens you how strong
do you become
unlimited unhumanly okay could you go
and walk to a concrete pillars
of a gate of a building
pick up the iron bars and rip the
concrete out of the ground
with the whole gate with the whole gate
carry it up onto a mountain and plonk it
down could you do that
he has his eyes wide open during the
vision and he does not breathe in those
speaks
that cannot be counterfeited without you
being dead right exactly
okay these are signs which cannot be
counterfeited in fact
modern so-called visionaries tend to
fall down with their eyes closed and
they have breath in them because only
god can sustain life without breath
simple yeah now god doesn't
always give a vision you can give a
dream yes
so but then you're asleep then you're
asleep you're not going to stand in
front of a crowd
giving a prophecy from god if it's not
done in this way or you're sleeping and
those that witness it
are over order
so now let's have a look at false
prophets so we have seven criteria
right physical manifestations and all
the others
jeremiah 23 25-28
i have heard what the prophet said that
prophesy lies in my name
saying i have dreamed i have dreamed
how long shall this be in the heart of
the prophets that prophesy lies yea
they are prophets of the deceit of their
own heart
which think to cause my people to forget
my name by their dreams which they tell
every man to his neighbor
as their fathers have forgotten my name
for baal
the prophets that hath a dream let him
tell the dream and he that has my word
let him speak my words
faithfully what is the chaff to the
wheat
says the lord so there will be dreamers
right
verse 32 32 says therefore behold i am
against the prophet says the lord that
steal my words
everyone from this neighbor so they're
talking to each other
and there can be many that agree with
the issue
so when the king of old wanted to know
shall i go up and
take this other nation on yeah
then the prophets came and danced and
said you will
be victorious you will
and there was a few of them yeah and the
king of judah was sitting there with the
king of israel and he said
excuse me isn't there a prophet of the
lord somewhere yeah
oh yeah there is one but i hate him let
him come
no he's not going to sing in harmony
with these
yeah therefore behold i'm against the
prophets
i'm against the prophet says the lord
that use their tongues and say he
has said behold i am against them that
prophesy false dreams says the lord and
do tell them
and cause my people to er by their lies
and by their likeness yet i sent them
not
nor commanded them therefore they shall
not profit this people
at all says the lord now again let's be
kind
these false prophets were they utterly
convinced that they were on the right
track
yes yes yes they thought they were doing
the right thing
they would even go to the true prophet
and give him a smack
all right and uh
in one occasion a prophet arose with
a yoke around him because god had said
put this yoke on you and a false prophet
came and broke the yoke
and god said to the true prophet go and
make yourself a
yoke of iron that they cannot break it
deuteronomy 18 20 to 22 but the prophet
which shall presume
to speak a word in my name which i have
not commanded him to speak
or that shall speak in the name of other
gods even that prophet shall die
if thou say in thy heart how shall we
know the word which the lord has not
spoken
when a prophet speaks in the name of the
lord if the thing follow not nor come to
pass that is the thing which the lord
has not spoken
but the prophet has spoken it
presumptuously thou shalt not be afraid
of him we'd looked at this verse before
yes i just want to say that one even
that prophet shall die
that's a serious proclamation absolutely
so
maybe that's a slight warning to
prophets out there
yes are you prepared to die for what you
say
if it does not come true and uh
god wants all of these people to be
saved because he doesn't want that
anyone should be lost
but rather that they repent and come
back into harmony with god's word
but it is a very serious thing to
even lead one of these my little ones
in the wrong direction because the blood
will be on your head
we have to be very careful before we say
we are prophets very very very
god showed me yes to
tell you and there's another point to
prophesy
doesn't necessarily mean that you have
received visions
that also can mean just to be a preacher
yes and even that is a dangerous job
because if you are a preacher and you
are not speaking in harmony with god's
word and leading people's
people astray then the same condemnation
comes upon your head
so we should be very very circumspect
maybe it's just a wake-up call to all
all of us yes don't take everything
lightly that has to do with god's word
and
that you speak to anybody be very
careful before you
accept something you're playing with
somebody's life
1 john 4 verse 1 beloved believe not
every spirit but try the spirits whether
they are of god because
many false prophets have gone out into
the world it's pretty
obvious that most of what you will hear
in the world is not true
no it'll be a minority
and many false prophets shall arise and
shall deceive many
matthew 24 11. what you just said
the truth is not popular no it's not
going to be popular
so now we're going to look at the number
of
prophecies in the world today and we
will apply
the criteria correct
correct and then this is not an attack
on anyone this is a an attempt to make
people aware
that we cannot just run with every
prophecy that is being predicted
out there in the world we have to be
very
very careful to the law and to the
testimony
okay here is a compilation of a number
of prophecies
in our modern time some of them were
from
sid roth's it's supernatural and there
are other channels
where certain prophets are going to
speak
and we will have a look at them and see
how they fit with the criteria that
we've just discussed
but i'll tell you here um it's not just
going to be
this administration it's not just going
to be the next four years or
eight years i saw 20 years
sid clearly i saw 20 years
and i believe it's even further because
the lord spoke to me and i saw in an
encounter
he said jeff when the last trump sounds
and i said what do you mean the last
trump sounds he said at the last trump
it will sound well the last trump and i
said lord what do you mean the last
trump it was a play on words
baron trump the associated press
said that joe biden is president
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah that's right yeah he's going to be
president mickey mouse is going to be
king yeah
yeah first of all i want to say without
a question
trump is going to win the election uh
and
that doesn't mean you sit home and don't
vote that means you get out and do
everything you can to work but he's
going to win
that's i think a given because i am
speaking
from the future yes you will this moment
right this man and i
am going to proclaim that president
trump
will be president of the united states
hallelujah
jesus name will be an eight-year
presidency absolutely
absolutely we will you're sure about
that i'm sure about that there's going
to be a
backlash and we're saying that a
populist backlash
merging with an awakening a spiritual
awakening
the two are going to fuse together and
you're going to see some
45 or 50 million people coming to christ
that's
one half of the people that voted for
donald trump that are devastated by
what's happening we have faith at least
half of the voters are christian the
other half are low-hanging fruit
and it's going to converge together to
create a sweeping
reset and we're coming into the absolute
revival battle of our lifetime right on
the horizon
we are in a time right now where god is
saying i've had enough
and that is why it is so important
christian to not be
fighting with one another fighting
against the prophets
listen it's very evident and i want to
follow up with something that mike
lindell said
regarding president trump he made it
very clear in his speech he's not going
anywhere
and when you saw the video clip those of
you that are watching tonight
of of biden it's very evident
we're not here to you know call out what
he's obviously having to deal with
but as far as in a sickness or whatever
is going on with him
but i can tell you this you don't see or
feel the anointing of the spirit of god
upon him because he's not been chosen
and elected of god
therefore when you listen to donald
trump and i did
and i heard his speech the anointing of
the holy spirit is not lifted off
that man and so we are in a reversal
we are in a reset we are in the greatest
days
where god is saying this nation will not
be
a socialistic or communist nation watch
and see taste and see the lord is good
and you're about to celebrate and
rejoice
in these coming months and years of what
god has planned
and i'm excited as it unfolds what
can and is god going to do in one day or
suddenly and that's what you got to
focus on this is not over
god is going to continue to interject
himself and what you need to do
like lance and the different ones are
saying here on this panel is engage
yourself
god is raising up people who are
dissatisfied
there has to come a point where the
flesh is between your teeth like the
children of israel who wanted quail
and you say you know what we've had
enough watch what god's about to do
things are going to shift the winds are
revealing it the ground is shaking it
and the volcanoes are erupting but
here's what god's doing he's
injecting himself and you're going to
see the amazing lord
rescue a nation rescue a people i've
seen the future
and it wasn't and it didn't look like
this there's a new america on the rise
well martin what is your summary of what
we have just heard
well you get a lot of them that that say
trump was going to win the election and
then now some of them says yeah but he
did win
but now he's not in empower power
and then there's a lot of them that say
he will come back now
he's going to have the presidency again
i don't know
this just sounds to me if we
compare it to what we've studied just
now
now it's evident are there many people
that
have become despondent now because what
the prophet
said didn't come to pass yes and do you
think there will be many that will say
well therefore god cannot be trusted and
they just leave religion behind
yeah all right so that's a real danger
right
the problem is like we saw in the
previous
um what's up prof that
the discredited people are being
discredited
for believing in the bible now you've
got people that believe in
the the prophecies of the bible and
things like this discredit
the bible now some of them were saying
he's definitely going to win and he's
going to have an eight-year term
now some of them will say well he'll win
the next one then he'll also have an
eight-year term
but it won't be this one and some of
them
are saying well we got it wrong and some
of them are
just modifying what they have been
saying
to the law and to the testimony
and they see for example the anointing
on one of the candidates and not on the
other one
how do you see that anointing how do you
determine whether there is an anointing
to the law and to the testimony do
any of them either trump
or biden did any of them
at any stage speak according to the law
and to the testimony no
neither of them neither neither they
might be
little glimpses of them speaking
like for instance um talking about jesus
and
giving them is going to a church a
criterium or going to a mass
is that a criterium if everything else
that you are saying
is not in harmony with with the law of
god etc
then you have a problem right so off the
bat we can say
none of them have spoken
according to the law and the prophets
well kenneth copeland went so far as to
say
to believe that biden is going to win is
like mickey mouse will become king right
yeah and he punctuated it with holy
laughter
so obviously that's a manifestation so
it must come true did it come true
no no he's the most obvious of the false
prophets
now here's an interesting one this is
chris yoon and
he has some interesting things to say
let's have a look
the lord has anointed and has appointed
uh trump to be
a president a second term it's not 2024
it's right now
in the next couple of weeks and i've
given a lot of prophetic word
and a lot of dreams and a lot of
different things throughout the last
couple of months and it's all leading up
to what's coming up in january 20th and
so i've said this many times before
but please reserve throwing your stones
at me until january 20th because
everyone is again
speaking too quickly they're taking news
just like the a few days after november
3rd
when a media declared biden the winner
you threw some stones
again the election certification you
threw some stones
but i've been saying wait till january
20th before
you say anything because right now more
than ever the lord has made it so clear
to me
what is about to come to pass and
everything i've been saying has so far
come to pass
and the grand finale has yet to come but
the question really
in the past week or two obviously is how
how are we
rectifying and remedying what is going
on are the prophets wrong
is um trump still at play like did
something go wrong did god change his
mind
there's a lot of different questions
that are being that are being thrown out
and i really believe that the lord has
given this opportunity for us
to remove ourselves from everything that
we've actually had
a tie to a hope to and this is targeting
all groups of people
right there are so many of us that have
relied so much on the prophetic word
which is good in that the bible says you
want to weigh and carefully discern but
so many of us have
idolized it we've just been so fixated
on it but the the word still stands and
i believe that the
the president uh trump he will still be
restored back to the office in some form
or not some form
clearly as president at some point soon
uh not in 2024 i believe it's going to
happen soon
as well as some kind of intervention
and i'm not saying military in the sense
that there's going to be some
um you know warfare takeover but there
whether it's some cyber warfare or
whether it's a mis information um you
know
thing or whatever it is that their
involvement is uh that's very secretive
that a lot of people argue people don't
know what's really going on there
now this one is very specific and very
interesting
so there were a number of dates there
with very specific predictions which did
not come to pass
then there was a modification of the
prediction
and then there was another modification
of the prediction
so clearly this is not true prophecy
right
there was even a part where he said we
may be
relying too much on the prophetic word
yes
but what is that prophetic word is it
the that which is in harmony with the
bible
or something that they assume came
directly from god
even if they had a dream or a vision now
you know what makes it very complicated
because at some stage
there might actually be an interesting
twist
and some things might actually happen
and some people haven't given up on the
idea
that there will be a turnaround i mean
there are
so many cube prophecies for example
that all of this is just a preparation
for the grand and glorious time that is
coming up on america
when the swamp will finally be drained
and all
those that have lived in disharmony
with the right principles will be put in
jail
or even executed i mean that's what the
prophecies say
right and they're saying that
military tribunals are busy with this
and there will be great changes in the
united states
be that as it may some of it might come
to pass some of it may not come to pass
but here's my question
what does the bible predict for
the united states does the bible
predict that the world will turn into
this
glorious place where you will have this
millennium
of great peace and beauty
does it say that there will be a great
apostasy
and that that will be followed by a
national ruin
yes that's what it says that's what the
book of revelation chapter 13 clearly
tells us
right and that there is a deception
so again it's not in harmony with the
testimony the testament the book of
revelation is part of the testimony
if by some wondrous event trump
gets back into office or so on it will
according to what the bible says will
happen
then it might be a temporary thing
it will not then it will be a deception
within a deception
you must test this to the law and the
prophets
yes what did the bible say what's going
to happen the bible
clearly tells us that the road
is a downward spiral
it is not a glorious revival
it might seem to be a glorious revival
because when they say
peace peace what comes decent safety
sudden destruction
sudden destruction so whatever they are
saying
whether parts of it come true or not
the final analysis it's not in harmony
with god's word
correct right yeah so
i we've covered most of the basis there
now
now martin in our next little video clip
we have
sid roth and he has some other
speakers as well right and
they are very much into prophecy now
this is not a personal attack
this is just looking at the facts as
they are
before us now he realized that his
prophecy
was incorrect and he apologized for that
which is
which is nice but he immediately follows
it up with a new prophecy and then
there's another speaker who comes
with an affirmation again predicting
this glorious future
which already is not in harmony with
what the bible has to say on the issue
so let's just have a look at what he has
to say
but i i want to sincerely ask
that's my pastor's heart that's that's
really the strong thing promoting this
i want to sincerely ask for forgiveness
for saying trump would serve another
term
and i do take full responsibility for
what i
said i'm especially sorry
for people whose faith
really was shaken
now you know this i'm sure if you're on
social media
that many of my friends that i endorse
as prophets
uh have gone on social media and
they believe that it's not over
and i have to tell you i pray
in yeshua's name that they're right
i know that and this is what i
call it you just got to bear with me
because god put it in my spirit and i'm
supposed to say it publicly
so i'm releasing it publicly i know
that the golden global glory i like
saying it that way
gold is trying and say it's a tongue
twister in a way
golden global glory is coming
this year it will be
a game changer prophecy
under the glory like this generation has
never
seen before casting demons out
i see auditorium so filled with the
glory of god
that the people who walk into the
auditoriums filled with demons
and will walk out with spirits of
infirmity having gone
with with spirits that have been
harassing them the whole life
because the golden global glory will
just
swoop in i'm speaking to people whose
bodies are holding them back i speak
healing right now
in the name of jesus i speak to every
every kind of
disease and i drive it out especially in
the kidneys and liver
lord god just cleanse those livers and
cleanse those kidneys right now
in the name of jesus and and all you
people that have
back pain i know that it's hard but the
lord wants to heal you right now
there's going to be a heat going up and
down your spine because the lord is
healing you right now
you see the lord is bringing justice on
your behalf right now
i'm addressing every evil spirit that is
hindering
any kind of prosperity right now in the
name of jesus i
break every evil spirit that has built
walls up to stop the money from coming
in
the money shall flow the lord's saying
it is not me that's holding it back from
you
it is broken now in the name of jesus i
am telling you by the spirit of god
prosperity is flowing to you you need to
just raise your hands right now and
worship god thank you father
for the release of finances thank you
father
whoa now if
if you look at sid
then you can feel some empathy for the
man
but immediately he again prophesies this
golden age
and we know that there will
be no golden age it is not biblical you
just have to read
the book of revelation the book of
revelation
does predict that there will be these
signs
and wonders that will take place but
then it
adds the word by which the inhabitants
will be deceived
yes so the signs and wonders
are something that we have to watch out
for and
martin when he says
people will be marching into a stadium
all deceived full of diseases
plagued by demons and march out the
other side
of the stadium perfectly
in harmony and under the glory of god
is that biblical no no
the bible says you must repent in other
words you must
turn around you must have a 180 degree
turn
you must walk in the other direction
such
were some of you says paul and then he
lists
all the criteria that we all qualified
for and our fallen nature sometimes
is drawn towards it's a constant battle
and if you don't live in harmony with
god's word
then the promises cannot apply yes
because
all the promises in the bible are
conditioned conditioned
yeah if then
if you will hearken unto them my word if
only you had listened to my commandments
then there's always that if
i hear now if do you hear if no
you're going to be healed your kidneys
are going to be cleaned yeah
did god give his people a health message
yes
what does he say about the glutton and
the and the wine baba
do they qualify for this kind of healing
no there must be a change you must come
back into harmony with god's word
that is true biblical
faith and healing and healing so
off the bat just looking at them
you would have to say that what we've
heard is not in harmony
with the law neither is it in harmony
with the testimony
correct all right here's an article in
the
christianity today magazine
and it's from january 20th failed trump
prophecies offer a lesson in humility
the failed prophecies of donald trump's
re-election may have damaged the
credibility
of the u.s independent charismatic wing
of evangelicalism more than any event
since the tele-evangelist scandal of the
1980s
now let's just stop there there's an
acknowledgement there that there have
been previous
scandals and it is largely the
charismatic wing
which is implicated now you come from
that background
the charismatic wing what does it say
about the law
it's gone and the bible says to the law
and to the testimony if they speak not
according to this word
they have no light in them
immediately off the bat you have a
problem right
as we approach the inauguration of
president joe biden
some who prophesied trump's re-election
remain adamant that they were correct
perhaps the election was stolen or will
be overturned or in some
mystical realm trump is still actually
spiritually president
some just change the subject
unfortunately their hardcore followers
may settle for that others acknowledge
that prophecy must be tested
by affirming biden's win now tacitly
concede that they were wrong
elijah prophesied the obliteration of
ahab's dynasty but god told him
afterwards that because of ahab's
repentance
the judgment would be delayed my
theologian friends
hold a range of views on how to explain
this
my personal understanding is that though
god
foreknows the outcomes he often speaks
to us just
what we need for the moment we need to
be ready to change the course
as needed
all right so this writer crave kinah
is relying here on the conditional
aspect of prophecy now
we must be careful here because when you
look at the conditional
aspect of prophecy then it
was always coupled to
obedience if you will do
if you will make right yes then
nineveh is a good example uh
if you look at the political
scene today is there any condition that
has been met has
the united states since the inauguration
of the new president
turned around to walk the path of
absolute righteousness
absolutely not no conditions have been
met that are in harmony with god's word
so basically off the bat
we can say that all of this
was basically not in harmony with god's
word
now our last video is interesting
because this is donald trump himself
speaking
yes and his speech
has so many elements that people
can hang their hopes on correct and this
is what's keeping it alive
and i'm wondering is this a game
is this a hegelian dialectic
is this something to introduce a state
of mind
or is there really something behind it
will there be a twist
in the tail i don't know
i'm not a prophet no but i do
have prophecy at my disposal
and i do understand from the word of god
and from the book of revelation
where this is going to head we're going
to have a conflict
it's going to be between the authority
of god and the authority of man
and there will have to be a choice and
before that
people will say when you make this
choice when you accept the mark of the
beast
great peace and prosperity will come but
then sudden destruction will follow
the greatest warning is given in
revelation chapter 14
when it comes to accepting the mark of
the beast
and that warning is not a warning of
peace and safety
no it is a warning of final destruction
so no matter what these people say none
of them
are speaking in harmony with god's word
yes
let's listen to that speech
together this week we're in the middle
of a historic struggle for america's
future
america's culture and america's
institutions
borders and most cherished principles
our security our prosperity and our very
identity as americans is at stake
like perhaps at no other time
so no matter how much the washington
establishment and the powerful
special interests may want to silence us
let there be no doubt we will be
victorious and america will be
stronger and greater than ever before
i also want to pay my love and respect
to the great rush limbaugh
who is watching closely
and smiling down on us he's watching and
he's loving it and he
loves catherine katzman thank you for
being here so great thank you kathryn
he loved you catherine i will tell you
that
and i want you to know that i'm going to
continue to fight
right by your side we will do
what we've done right from the beginning
which is to win
we're not starting new parties
you know they kept saying he's going to
start a brand new party
we have the republican party it's going
to unite
and be stronger than ever before i am
not starting a new party
that was fake news this alone should be
reason enough
for democrats to suffer withering losses
in the midterms and
to lose the white house decisively
four years from now i may even decide
to beat them for a third time okay
with your help we will take back the
house
we will win the senate and then
a republican president will make a
triumphant
return to the white house and i wonder
who that will be
who who who will that be i wonder
standing before you today i am supremely
confident
that for our movement for our party
and for our country our brightest days
are just ahead and that together we will
make
america prouder freer stronger and
greater
than it ever has been before thank you
cpac god bless you and god bless america
thank you all
thank you now martin that was a rousing
speech right
and it got the people to their feet and
they were clapping
yep and he might even beat them for the
third time
so he's hinting at the midterm elections
and the next elections
and wonderful things to happen and this
great prosperity
it's this golden age okay
to the law and to the testimony
now he didn't claim to be a prophet here
but the prophets are latching on to what
he is saying and prophesying
prophesying on his behalf now did he not
refer to someone who had died
yes rush limbaugh rush limbaugh
and he's watching right now is that
according to the law and the testimony
nope no because the dead no nothing
nothing they have no part in anything
that goes on
on under the sun so there is falsehood
intermingled with this glorious speech
of hope
and people are roused and believe
that things will change and the
q anon conspiracy theory
is kept alive in a sense yes
even the new age um
philosophy is kept that rise alive
with a golden age of prosperity golden
age now none of that
is in harmony with the scripture so our
appeal
to everyone is to make the word of god
your guide
and to use the word of god
to be your cleaver as to
what fits the prophetic scenario
and what does not and if we do that
then we will not be deceived by every
wind of
doctrine every sign and wonder that
takes place out there
every word that is prophesied with so
much pomp and glamour and holy laughter
and
whatever signs there are i just want to
also put in
that that one prophet didn't show on the
video
but he uses the volcanoes and the
eruptions and the earthquakes and all of
these
as in prophesying that these signs are
helping
to edify what he's saying correct
and now martin just one last point
in the scientific world there are many
prophets as well
and these prophets are not now
prophesying in terms of religious
matters but in terms of
environmental issues right
and some are saying we have x number of
months
some of them are so accurate that
they'll tell you how many days we have
left before this planet is finished
and some of these prophecies have of
course failed in the past
do we apply some of those criteria as
well
well we should look at that maybe we
must do another one
yep on the environmental profits and see
what is happening on that score
definitely
because the world is going absolutely
insane and laws are being
enacted yes and the interesting thing is
that the laws that are being enacted
no matter on the basis of whatever
philosophy the laws are in harmony with
what
the bible predicts will happen laws of
buying and selling
laws of freedom laws of access
all of those are being mentioned in the
bible
and it's happening so whether you're
looking at the religious field whether
you're looking at the scientific field
and both of them are glorified
to the x amount today if you speak
against
science you are an ignoramus
yeah in fact you are a conspiracist well
in in amid evil terms you are a heretic
correct
so these are very important times that
we are living in
and may god give us wisdom and may god
give us discernment and may god give
us the willingness to test
everything out there by the word of god
let's pray heavenly father
there is so much deception in the world
and even the deceivers and the deceived
do not know that they are on a road
that leads to a conflict
with the very prophecies that tell us
what will happen
in the world and in our future
give us wisdom lord to study your word
and to make the word
the criterium and nothing else is my
prayer
in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you